I have no idea what do you know about
the furry like that's the name of them
or you just mean in general furry
animals they would tails on what do you
know about furries specifically for
reading nothing I don't know man they
just have like starfox and make each
other oh my gosh you guys are wait I now
feel better like laugh at a person this
is different
my name is Lumia Draco that is my fur
name and I am a celestial moon dragon my
fur sona is Haven feschi I've been in
the furry community slash fandom for
four years now I have been in the fandom
for I want to say going on seven years
now I've never had one of those moments
where are they right behind me but as
soon as I started making jokes about
furries I heard the rattling and I'm
assuming y'all don't commit a lot of
crimes you can't sneak up on the furry
community is essentially enthusiasts of
anthropomorphic animals which means
animals with human-like characteristics
I've had so many questions and now I'm
just like frozen most because y'all
still look like y'all could hurt me you
don't have any fur
I don't just call us scaly scaly yes how
you address is how you see yourself yeah
it's called a persona where do you
usually go in character whatever there's
an opportunity yeah
but commonly the furry community has
their own furry conventions that they go
to other than conventions I go out to
clubs like this and then also I've done
charity I've done parades go to
children's hospitals so I kind of
brighten up their day we actually have a
group that's devoted to doing it on a
weekly basis to children oh that's
incredible
I have to ask how white is how white is
for you just bluntly bluntly speaking
it's pretty white there's a group that
just started doing POC focus
room parties yeah and I'm like yes
that's awesome that's amazing it's very
open across the spectrum of LGBT one of
the biggest diversity and our fandom is
we come from a wide spectrum of sexual
orientation gender identity and gender
expression I've been an out in open gay
man for many years and what I found with
the community because we sort of exist
as these characters we are much more
likely to open up a lot of people who
enter into this community
they're very pressure to be someone that
they're not by Korean a4 so no can alter
that and have the ability to really
discover who you are from a third-person
perspective do you only do relationships
with other furries or do you have like a
furry relationship versus like human
relationship you know I'm one of those
I'm I would be open either way as long
as I feel that we're going to get along
in general then you know it doesn't
matter and if they can deal with this
every now and then so I've seen like
some furry porn I guess uh-huh you know
they do have the ears and they have the
bunny tail and I've seen and I haven't
seen two people in costumes is that a
bit like okay so because we're adults
here you know you have to say it's
something that does happen but it's not
as often as people think there are
people that enjoy the adult aspects of
it and I think that's okay but it's not
the sort of levels of debauchery that
you know people think think it may be I
would say the main misconceptions would
be that it's a fetish it is not it's an
interest it can be a lifestyle it can be
whatever you want it to be for me
personally it's about self exploration
and self-expression people think that
we're the worst of the worst that we
don't have anywhere else to go and so we
sort of fall into the fandom but it's
entirely untrue I think we're some of
the best of what we have to offer
society as people and as our characters
before you get to know us when we come
across this kind of weird or
what-have-you but we come from all walks
of life all professions I mean we have
doctors and lawyers and engineers and
and the famous one is a chemist dr.
uncle Khan okay you know if we were like
secretly Will Smith's the Scientologists
are only people with a child Loki no as
a furry we like that like like Emma
Stone actually a furry but people don't
know yeah furries who are in suit is
like 15% of the fandom you look around
in your own social circle you probably
have someone who is referring themselves
I think I'm like halfway on my way to
being a first oh yeah you should create
a persona I should if you were to wake
up tomorrow as an animal what would that
analytic sea bear swim good it has to be
like some kind of bear with flight right
now I'm really into elephants which
would be really for my size some kind of
flighted bear I can yeah like a swoop in
and grab salmon like I kind of like
really and this is weird maybe but uh
two of Phoenix cuz I've been through a
lot and then I've still managed to pull
myself up I could do a beautiful
colorful slob absolutely that sleeps a
lot I don't know what to call it though
yeah that's the next question is you
know what will be the name I wanted to
have s's so it all flow like sloth love
do people do regular names like a
giraffe named Darius somewhere I keep
coming up with like silly like Buffy
sort of names like like what like Buffy
I'm like Sasha eyelashes laughs I like
that I'm going like Xander but trying to
feminize it yeah eggs and II like that
is Andy the Phoenix I can't think of a
name let's let's use the drag name the
name of the first Street they grew up on
and first pet's name that's it
Melrose Pauley what the community means
to me is a sense of family sometimes we
come from families that so it can be
very abusive to us so it's nice to
you have a family that really does care
about us and really allows us to be who
we want to be now they were super sweet
and I figured they'd be sweet it's
actually really unfortunate that they
have such a negative stereotype against
them because they're just wonderful
people who want to go out escape and
make everyone else happy and that's a
wonderful thing I just think people who
don't think it's a good idea probably
have a hard time being their authentic
self because if you can be who you are
and have fun life is a lot more
enjoyable what you feel that you're
missing in your life you probably can
and will find that within this this
particular fandom and within this
community just don't judge anybody even
if they're dressed up like Adam when it
doesn't exist because they're probably
nice and it's not all about is they're
like is that like a higher is there like
a Grand Wizard hey unsolved is on a new
channel and now you're part subscribe
here that was my part